uh there has been heavy gunfire in
guinea bissau near the government
headquarters in the capital bazaar the
west african regional block ecowas has
called it an attempted coup the cabinet
meeting was being held at the time uh
nick hack has been following
developments from dhaka and senegal
joins us on skype nick what more do you
know
well there's a precarious calm right now
in the capital of guinea-bissau bissau
we know that the military have taken
control of key locations within the
capital so the presidential palace is in
the hand of the military the palace for
the government is in the hand of the
military the minister of interior and
other key
government buildings what's interesting
here is we still have no news from the
prime minister and the president gunfire
erupted just around 12 o'clock local
time when he uh president embalo was
holding a cabinet meeting
eyewitness saw soldiers um
launching an assault on the palace of
the government where that meeting has
been taking place and we've seen stern
words already from the west african body
ecowas um asking for the military to
return to their barracks and alluding
for of of this potential coup and also
from the un secretary
general saying that he's deeply
concerned over the events that are
taking place in bisal so still a lot of
confusion on who's in charge and who's
behind what seems to be an attempted
kubnik
nick what's the context of this
especially given the ongoing instability
in the region
well first of all misawa is very it's
it's familiar to kuz there's been nine
coups since it got its independence and
there's always been a tussle of power
between elected officials and and the
military in fact no elected official in
guinea-bissau has ever been able to
finish his time in office and um there
was an attempted coup in october that
was foiled and when we were in misawa
last during the elections uh the
election results were called into
question by the opposition and then by
the constitutional court that um that
stamp that confirmed ambalo's election
but ever since there's been some unease
in in the ranks of the military you have
to also remember the context and and
of guinea-bissau for the state
department it sees this as a narco state
and there's been members senior members
of the military
that have been accused of trafficking
cocaine um from colombia through guinea
bissau
to european markets to europe and and
and the united kingdom so
there's there's an element of mistrust
between the government and
parts of the security forces one of the
main challenges for imbala since has
come to power is try to unite people
behind his elected officials but it
seems right now that that's being called
into question precarious calm right now
on the streets of bisaw but this comes
as perhaps the latest coup in the region
river nick last week aku in burkina faso
and a few months earlier a coup in
guinea in september and then earlier
than that in in there was a coup in mali
that's the fourth coup
in the region a major setback for
democracy according to
ghana's president nana akufa ardo
who will be chairing the west african
body ecowas extraordinary summit on
thursday to discuss what seems to be um
the setback in democracy and its
institutions
so
they're condemning what appears to be a
coup still on news of where the
president is and we're waiting to hear
more from
nick
back with you soon as we uh gather more
information nick for the time being
thanks very much indeed nicholas hack
reporting there